we start here in germany which has
hit an unfortunate milestone in the
coronavirus pandemic
the country has again recorded more than
22
000 new daily cases pushing its total
beyond the one million mark that's
according to figures from the robert
caulk institute for disease control
germany largely contained the viruses
spread during the first wave in the
spring
but it's been hit hard by the second
wave of infections
astrazeneca is planning an additional
global trial of its covet 19 vaccine
that after scientists raised doubts
about the initial results showing the
shot to be 90 percent effective in a
test
where participants by error received a
half dose followed by
a full dose experts said that problems
with the first trial could hinder
astrazeneca's chances of getting speedy
u.s and eu regulatory approval
for its covet-19 drop the company says
a new trial would focus on evaluating a
lower dosage
astrazeneca is just one company that has
published results claiming high efficacy
for the vaccine
but none has yet received regulatory
approval in the u.s
or the eu when that happens and vaccines
are rolled out
one challenge will be ensuring that they
are fairly distributed around the globe
first covet 19 vaccines on the verge of
being authorized
billions of vaccine doses have already
been secured by wealthy countries
this has raised concerns that the jab
will arrive much later
at low-income countries to avoid that
an initiative was founded kovacs
backed by the who countries representing
two-thirds of the world population have
joined
kovac's goal is to make sure all member
states get vaccines
regardless of financial means but how
does it work
on its website kovacs explains its
strategy
member states pool their efforts and
money to support the development of
several vaccine candidates
instead of competing against each other
they then negotiate their pricing
together
therefore keeping prices low once
effective vaccines are available
it says all participating countries
regardless of income levels will have
equal access to these vaccines for lower
income countries it is the only viable
way
in which their citizens will get access
to covet 19 vaccines
but wealthy countries have other options
states like the uk
and countries of the u have joined the
initiative
but they've also made bilateral deals
with manufacturers on the side
these bilateral agreements have created
an imbalance
between the different members critics
say why
poor countries are solely dependent on
kovacs wealthier ones
use it as an add-on to its bilateral
deals
and there is more critics argue that
these bilateral deals make it harder for
kovacs to do its job
because when a big share of jabs is
already promised to individual countries
covex can only distribute what is left
for many hotter countries not all
vaccines will be equally
suitable for practical reasons they are
likely to prefer those
easier to transport without a difficult
cold chain to maintain
and finally big countries like the us
and russia haven't even joined the
initiative
instead of supporting kovacs they've
only invested in the development of
their own vaccines
kovacs nevertheless is sticking to its
goal
by the end of next year it wants to have
2 billion doses distributed
around the globe
joining me now is elena books from the
german ethics council that's an
independent council of experts
who advise the german government on
questions of ethics science and law
elena welcome to dw we just saw in the
report that some countries are trying to
position themselves
to access vaccines first but shouldn't
the most needy countries
be the first in line
well there's a real conflict here
because countries of course have an
obligation to look after their own
populations
so that's not wrong per se but at the
same time the pandemic won't be over
until all countries can access enough
vaccines
we're all in this together so this is a
time to do two things at the same time
look after your own population but also
help other countries to access enough
vaccines for their population so we'll
need to find a balance here we're all in
this together germany is not taking part
in the kovacs program
some might argue that's an example of a
rich country exploiting its wealth while
others have to wait
well i believe it's very important that
germany does participate in
these kinds of initiatives because we do
have the means
we're very fortunate we have one of the
first vaccines that actually comes from
germany
um but again we are in the middle of
europe so we are one of the countries
that knows we can't isolate ourselves
we're not an island
and that counts for the entire world so
i really do believe that we need to show
some solidarity here
so break it down for us what should the
priorities be when deciding who should
be vaccinated first
well within a country we for example the
council
suggest it recommended that it should be
those with the highest risks
very old people in care homes for
example those looking after
such people because they expose
themselves to risks
such as workers in the healthcare system
and then people that have
very important functions and roles in
society
internationally it will depend on how
hard a country is affected but it will
also i'm
afraid depend on some practical aspects
because some of these vaccines
require some very high tech distribution
and a very developed health care systems
so we will have to
push for vaccines that can be deployed
everywhere
and one of the duties of richer
countries is to support development of
vaccines
that can be shipped around the entire
world
what advice specifically are you giving
the german government on how to
distribute vaccines
we recommend it for national
distribution
these three groups that i just mentioned
so those with the highest risk
fast than those who look after people
with the highest risk
healthcare workers and then people with
particularly important functions in
society
we did not issue advice on the
international allocation although we did
discuss
exactly the kinds of questions that we
just talked about
thank you so much for that perspective
elena books much appreciated
thank you well by the time christmas
arrives germany will know
more about the impact of a major holiday
on controlling the virus
thanks to what is happening now in the
united states
today is thanksgiving one of the most
important u.s holidays
the day before thanksgiving is the most
heavily traveled day of the year in
america
but this year public health officials
advised people to stay home
or risk creating a super spreader
event when not everyone heeded that
warning
after more than eight months of social
distancing many are
simply eager to see family and friends
again
50 million people are expected to drive
or fly by this coming sunday
95 percent of those are expected to
travel by car
only five percent are flying this year
but that is still two and a half
million people
well it is a tradition on thanksgiving
to visit the grandparents but this year
grandmothers grandfathers and many
elderly
will spend the holiday alone a
washington-based restaurant owner is
trying to combat the loneliness by
feeding the stomach and the soul
thanksgiving celebrations have always
been about food
lots of food traditional cornbread
stuffing
sweet potatoes
and then of course the turkey
they say people gain seven pounds over
thanksgiving
this one meal could probably do it this
year though
many americans will eat alone
corona has turned cooking and eating
with others into a danger
especially for the elderly this is where
mark bucher and his team
stepped in we just wanted to make sure
that the older population had a
thanksgiving meal
because there's one meal that's really
hard to make if not impossible to make
for one person
that's thanksgiving so we can make it
for them
mark posted his offer of a free meal for
people over 70
on social media he was expecting about
200 people
would reply but 5 000 asked him for
dinner
we found a group
of our population that's starving
and they are scared to death to leave
their apartments
and as a result they just don't want a
thanksgiving dinner
they're depending on the thanksgiving
dinner
so he called on his restaurant stuff to
get working
the meals are paid by donations
volunteers are bringing a signal of
solidarity
as well as dinner it's thanksgiving
thank you i often went to family or to
my friend's house for many years
and this year no wedding can't go
anywhere
how do you feel about this pretty sad
it's been you know
locked in the house for a long time and
you're by yourself and
you know it's you and the cat just me
and the cats
so that's how i'm spending it except now
i'm going to have the meal
it's very scary when when you can't buy
food the way you used to buy food
i just peeked in the bag it looked
wonderful looked wonderful
thank you so much a bright moment in
hard times
and new priorities for a restaurant
owner this isn't my job
this is my responsibility
good news on this thanksgiving well
let's take the story now to washington
d.c
my colleague carolina chamoy she is
working on this thanksgiving carolina
happy thanksgiving to you
happy thanksgiving to you brent we know
that fewer people are traveling in
america this week
but public health officials say the
numbers are still too high
tell me i mean you've been out and about
what have you observed
well we know that the cdc the centers
for disease control and prevention
posted already a long list a week ago at
least
of update guidelines for safely
celebrating thanksgiving this includes
of course
wearing a mask keeping gathering small
and if possible outside
and they also say that an older adult or
a person with
certain medical conditions that they
should completely avoid
in-person gatherings with people who
don't do not live
in their household and this makes it of
course a very difficult brand because
as you know thanksgiving is precisely
about
family and friends and this includes of
course elderly people so
this day feels also a bit sad here in
the united states for a lot of families
but the risk is huge we have to say that
the united states has already over 12
million cases to report on more than 260
000
deaths and this is really boring yeah i
mean i speak from personal experience
can't be with my family because of the
pandemic this year
what about the nation's um airports are
we seeing a lot of people flying
well the cdc has also recommended
against
traveling this week and for thanksgiving
especially
but still millions have traveled through
the airports in the united states to
enjoy this day
with their families students parents
siblings
or just families who want to gather as
they have always been doing they don't
want to change anything
in their lives because of covet 19 and
uh dr anthony fauci
uh the country's top effect infectious
disease expert
remember he said that people in airports
that they are going to get the united
states into even more trouble
than we are right now already we went
yesterday to dallas international
airport in washington and we talked to
some of the travelers let's take a look
brent
travel was great no problems whatsoever
everybody that i've seen was you know
paying attention to the social
distancing and everything everybody's
wearing masks
so there wasn't any problems whatsoever
travel was actually a whole lot easier
than what i thought it was going to be
well as you see people some of them feel
comfortable
and the thing is a brand that traveling
seems to be safe but it's not really you
don't know who you might be infecting
also very important to consider the
symptoms
after covet 19. what if someone already
had the
the this infection these are also
symptoms that have to be
taken very seriously and these are
things that a lot of people who we
talked to yesterday at the airport are
not considering
yeah that's a very good point to make
what about the messages that americans
are hearing the message is from
president trump and president-elect
biden on this thanksgiving they
really could hardly be more different
right
you're completely right brent but this
isn't really surprising is it
i mean donald trump as we know has not
been taking this pandemic seriously from
day number one on and joe biden he
called
um for solidarity during a speech
yesterday he was
making people feel that he knows how
difficult it is
to keep the distance in in in a day like
today in a day that is supposed to be
full of
uh hacks and and gatherings and not
really a social distance
all right twu's carolina chamoy with the
latest tonight on this thanksgiving
in washington d.c carolina thank you
very much have a happy and a healthy
thanksgiving